this video is brought to you by
manscaped hello everyone and welcome
back to mark pronounces japanese names
and words incorrectly otherwise known as
my blind review series last week i
covered the reintroduction of the main
characters after the time skip the
retrieval of gara and their respective
battles against the akatsky group
responsible for much of the conflict in
the second half of the video i've been
covering naruto for a couple months now
and with me now well into my 37th volume
of the story i think this material i'm
covering today might just be my favorite
in quite a while exploring the sinister
and surprising tenshi bridge mission the
new scope of naruto's power and a
touching story with shikamaru the likes
of which i never saw myself becoming so
invested in i'm honestly so excited to
discuss with you all my thoughts on
these two arcs so let's dive into the
tense tenshi bridge reconnaissance
mission and the supremely well-written
akatsuki suppression mission
before i jump into things i quickly want
to let you know what i have planned for
december initially i had planned on
taking this december off but instead how
about this spider-man no way home hits
theaters this december 17th and so i
thought it might be fun if this december
we go full spider themed in a challenge
i am dubbing spidey sember it's a
brilliant name within which i will
attempt to review and break down some of
the most iconic and heavily criticized
live-action spider-man films ever to be
released i'm talking garfield i'm
talking toby maguire i'm talking tom
under my umbrella ella holland i'll be
making three videos kicking things off
this spy december with the raimi trilogy
on december 2nd which i haven't seen
since i was a kid in theaters i can't
wait to share with you all my feelings
on these films that honestly changed my
life and i hope to see you there for
this spy december
[Music]
something i haven't complimented naruto
as much for in this series is its
consistent sense of flow in the past
i've criticized shows like dragon ball
super for failing broadly speaking like
a collection of short story arcs with
clear-cut beginnings and endings with
little to no connective tissue between
arcs themselves to help create a sense
that there's this grand story or
adventure in the original dragon ball so
many of the arcs flowed naturally into
each other providing setups and payoffs
for themselves in other words it
successfully felt like a single massive
story and thankfully i can say the same
is true for naruto something happens in
one arc and so therefore those actions
or outcomes necessarily impact the
coming narrative the tuning exams led to
the ambush which led to the third
hokage's death which led to the search
for tsunade etc etc everything in this
universe feels connected which in turn
for me at least helps me to feel that
much more invested in each and every
narrative choice that's made because i
know that each and every narrative
choice is likely to directly impact the
future
there were a few things that stuck with
me after the conclusion to last week's
material firstly it was the amicable
nature gara embraced naruto with
highlighting that these two are the only
two people in their respective circles
that truly understand each other and due
to that fact the lengths naruto went to
four gara really helped to highlight how
far he has come socially now surrounded
by the family he always wanted and has
now acquired despite the losses that
took place to make all of this possible
representing a dated way of thinking now
passing on there was kakasha's ability
to use the variation on the mangekyo
sharingan which on its own is awesome
but speaks to a sadness for his past
where he lost a friend in obito in a
nutshell my reaction to it was oh my god
this is so oh
no it's really sad isn't it
and finally the introduction of a new
character called psy my first impression
of psy was that he was creepy and
underhanded and while all of my
assessment was technically correct what
he offers to this story is so much more
than that simple first impression from a
consistency perspective he slots into
the story rather seamlessly despite him
being a relative unknown before this
introduction with him coming from the
black ops foundation he seems like a
natural addition to the team of sakura
and naruto seeing as they at this point
were missing kakashi and sasuke in their
cell however despite sai joining the
team naruto and sakura still needed a
leader to help them follow through on
this lead provided by sasori in the
previous arc the lead informed them of a
scheduled meeting he had organized with
a mole he had in the ranks of arochimaru
which happens to be exactly where naruto
wants to be due to the importance of
this mission lady tsunade employs the
help of yamato a level-headed and
grounded older ninja descended from the
first hokage this guy didn't make a
massive impression on me but he does
offer a useful mechanism that does come
into play later and overall seems like a
swell and balanced fellow by and large
he doesn't offer a massive amount
emotionally to the story but in terms of
facilitating the plot no other character
helps in that respect more
once again broadly speaking i think psy
is an interesting character for two
reasons i mentioned that within the
story it made sense for him to join
their ranks to help out however it's
what this fellow represents for the
series that i think offers his true
strengths within this narrative firstly
he seems to be the embodiment of what
shinobi are in this world raised by the
black ops forces he doesn't possess any
emotion or even understanding of how
other people react or think he's an
extreme manifestation of the tool for
destruction and espionage that have been
espoused by the higher ups of this world
even by the third hokage himself at one
point that's one reason why he's
interesting the second reason is how he
complements and contrasts naruto i've
spoken about the importance of crania
contrast character for naruto the main
character to amplify his own personality
sasuke was that for naruto first and at
various points in the narrative that
role has shifted to different
individuals in this instance saifu fills
that role so many of his values run
counter to naruto's and just like
clockwork he brings out the best in
articular ninja what's also interesting
with this character is the effect he has
on both naruto and sakura by bluntly and
coldly addressing the actions of sasuke
he puts pressure on both of them to
justify sasuke's behavior leading to a
variety of refusals from naruto to work
with him in the first place and many
many outbursts the best of which was
this
this is what i mean when i say psy
brings out the best in naruto what was
once rage and childish retaliation has
been replaced with a cam unflinching
resolve when he starts to realize that
these words from psy don't necessarily
come from a place of intentional
antagonism but instead from a genuine
and troubling bewilderment that's only
interested in looking at the situation
from a cold utilitarian standpoint
tenshi bridge this section had me
stressed the hell out and i truly mean
that apart from the plan as it currently
is being extremely shaky no matter what
way you look at it trying to impersonate
the story we also have the wild card
inside and we learn that the informant
is kabuto and on top of that the fact
that kabuto is actually a triple agent
there to portray and kill cesari and you
have for yourself a page turner unlike
any i've seen from this series in a long
while also there's this instance in this
act where lady tsunade is looking out
and notices an animal jumping out from
the brush and once again this happens
here at the bridge i thought this was
interesting as it turns out it's
actually a rochimaru lying in wait which
made me think was he at the village too
i mean i love stuff like that because
even if it wasn't it's still a cool
piece of paranoia kishimoto's injected
into my mind which is great because now
we're primed for a spectacular fight and
this fight is all of that and a bag of
chips something this arc does a
phenomenal job with is making the fight
feel personal as soon as yamato sees
orochimaru and everything on the bridge
starts turning south he signals for the
others this was a brilliant touch to add
drama to this story with a great piece
of visual storytelling through naruto
immediately showing signs of losing
himself to that more aggressive and
feral fox spirit state he's been in
before this is an incredibly important
and emotional battle for naruto and to
see this reinforced by his immediate
elevation into the state without warning
was brilliant however what made me fall
in love with this section wasn't
necessarily the cool visuals but the
meaning and narrative behind them and
the consequences thereafter there's a
heavy amount of emphasis placed on
jiraya's words as he explains to yamato
what he went through while training
naruto over the last number of years
informing him not to allow too many
tales to reveal themselves as naruto
needs more and more power with them
effectively acting as a mechanism to
display how far gone naruto has lost
himself to the fox spirit itself as i
said it all looks very impressive
however as naruto powers up to attack
orochimaru and kabuto this happens
there's an obvious lesson to learn here
for naruto but remember what i said
about this being an emotional and
personal fight for more than one person
well while i saw and enjoyed what naruto
offered in this situation i was
completely taken aback by how sakura
reacted to being hurt in the process of
this power up when she wakes she doesn't
feel hurt or emotionally shocked by
naruto's attack instead her reaction is
perfectly in keeping with her own
existing motivations she sees this as a
direct result of not naruto being
selfish or losing control unnecessarily
but instead her own prior weaknesses she
couldn't bring sasuke back and as a
result naruto made a promise to bring
sasuke back no matter what and as it
happens no matter what in this instance
means this it's extreme to say the least
he's on the brink and he may even lose
his life this sort of clear-headedness
and honest accountability on behalf of
sakura is not only refreshing to hear
but incredibly brave and noble too after
seeing this reaction from sakurai it
honestly felt like she had grown the
most during the time skip it's a
remarkable difference on the naruto
front the finesse humanity and technique
of him is completely gone at this point
there are no familiar techniques on
display like the shadow clones which is
a great touch i think to make this form
feel like an embodiment of something
naruto isn't and when you combine that
with the fact that he's up against
orochimaru it's in every sense of the
word no longer a battle between ninja
but monsters at this point sakura does
try to help and bring naruto back from
the brink once again but she gets hurt
in the process
alright so this was visually awesome and
super fun to read through it felt
immensely cathartic watching orochimaru
on the back foot during this encounter
we haven't seen him fight all out in a
while and this fox spirit really seems
to be pushing him back at every turn
again the layer on page spreads are
fitting for the occasion but if i'm
being honest the best stuff comes after
the smoke clears and yamato using his
special abilities is able to seal away
that spirit and bring naruto back from
that breaking point this is where yamato
proves himself as a worthy leader and
noble ninja in my opinion his
confrontation with naruto concerning the
responsibility he has to do his best
without the help of the fox spirit is
exactly what i was getting at last week
this spirit provides a welcome shortcut
and might even feel empowering naruto
very clearly wants something and at this
point this seems like the easiest route
to meet that goal however there are
clear and easily identifiable drawbacks
to this line of action and this is a
common angle in coming of age stories
take sam raimi's spider-man 3 for
example it's not everyone's favorite
film but it tries to tell this exact
story the venom symbiote while offering
some more power and freedom comes at the
cost of what makes peter parker himself
leading to him hurting those around him
the exact same thing happens to naruto
in this instance capping off the
confrontation with a quote so perfect
from yamato i'd put it up there as one
of my favorite quotes from this entire
series the source of your strength
naruto is in the foxtail spirit it's
your own if you want to help sasuke do
it using your own power if you want to
protect sakura do it using your own
strength
brilliant this portion of the story is
where yamato's upsides really shine for
me as a new addition to the main squad
on top of being a noble level-headed
leader type he's also skilled in a wide
and rare variety of jutsu one that comes
in massively handy when sai who had been
missing during the encounter with
orochimaru attempts to join forces with
him and leaves promptly along with
kabuto and himself thankfully however
yamato has a tracker on him and little
does i know that he's about to lead him
to where orochimaru's hiding with sasuke
this is a fantastic chance for them to
save him and a chance for naruto to show
that he can control his desire to
relinquish control to the spirit inside
of him
once they confront psy in his cell the
true scope of what he represents in this
series is plain as day while yes he
represents broadly speaking what ninjas
mean in this world specific to him he
also has a sketchbook which reveals a
lot more about him and the process he
was created within in the first place
once upon a time having a brother
someone who cherished him who cared for
him and someone who held on to a
specific sketchbook for however when he
died sai lost any and all memory of what
he was going to put into that book for
his brother
this book itself represents psy's lost
humanity in conversations he refers to
himself as no one nobody a clean slate
that can act as an extension of danzo's
will a product of the foundation's cruel
methods to expunge him of all that made
him who he was in the first place or at
least that seems to be the case until
recently for when he realizes he's lost
that sketchbook he shows visible concern
proving to us the readers and viewers
that while his humanity might not be
visible on the surface deep down tied to
what that book represents are the
remnants of who he really is as a person
there's a confrontation between naruto
and say where naruto tries to explain to
him his reasoning as to why he's so
determined to save sasuke from those
circumstances despite his desire to stay
and have nothing more to do with him and
in it i think there's a connection being
made between naruto meaning nothing to
sasuke and psy referring to himself as
no one despite sasuke actively seeing
naruto as quote nothing just because
someone says something isn't so doesn't
remove the bond that exists between two
people that genuinely cared for each
other this speaks to sai's relationship
with his brother when faced with psy
further questioning why naruto insists
on trying to save someone in sasuke
instead of getting angry naruto
compassionately and calmly explains his
relationship with sasuke and his
determination in the face of impossible
odds to never stop fighting for him and
in a way it's as if he's directly
speaking to psy himself and while a very
solemn scene i think it's really
effective and at this moment naruto
feels like he's recent understanding
with side perhaps for the first time
since he's met him leading to him for
the first time actually trusting him to
carry out an important job to locate
sasuke in this hideout and it's here
that kishimoto decides to once again
place some paranoia and doubt in our
minds as he reveals psy's original plan
wasn't to help their team or to even be
a conduit between danzo and orochimaru
but instead to specifically assassinate
sasuke whether or not the experiences
and epiphanies he's had since meeting
naruto will be enough to dissuade this
mission is another question but either
way with good intentions or not he's
running to sasuke's location it's super
exciting as the decision sai makes once
he reaches sasuke will effectively
define his true intentions and really
his character i love stuff like this it
makes me rethink the entire interaction
he had with naruto asking questions like
did he master emotional deception like
what sakura did to him earlier in the
story and even if he hasn't the very
fact that kishimoto got me thinking and
asking these questions is proof that he
absolutely nailed this tension building
sequence thankfully though as it happens
sai turns out to be a good boy
[Music]
the reunion between sasuke and the
others feels monumental it very much
feels like the culmination of everything
that's been built up to so far and
kishimoto goes all out in dedicating as
much real estate as possible within the
chapter this scene takes place in for
massive page spreads to fully capture
the emotion of that moment from the
first time seeing each other in years to
close-ups of their respective reactions
to seeing each other there are so many
full-page spreads that at points it
almost looks like a coloring book and i
mean that in the best possible way they
look very impressive with the
expressions positioning and staging of
characters offering plenty in the way of
tone setting furthermore this sequence
deals with some of my favorite subject
matter and comes packed with some
wonderful imagery to convey what's
happening to boot when battling with
sasuke we get to see a host of new
abilities he's clearly been working on
working on still with the single-minded
purpose of finding and killing his
brother to him now he claims that
nothing else matters to him except his
brother's death even if it means merging
with orochimaru this i don't think i
believe though it's almost as if he
wants to convince himself that and i say
that because of what happens later on my
favorite part of this encounter has to
be the struggle naruto is undergoing and
not just with sasuke but himself a
struggle to resist the allure of tapping
into the fox spirit's power and to
increase his chances of forcibly taking
sasuke back home it's a wonderful
example of naruto putting others first
and showing belief in himself to do what
needs to be done with his own power and
strength however there is something that
makes this scene a little more freaky
while naruto is trying to center himself
in his mind and subdue the fox spirit
sasuke is there in his mind with himself
and the fox it's a first in the series
and in being such it really gives sasuke
an air of superiority and control the
likes of which we've not seen so far
however once again while sasuke says
that nothing else matters to him other
than his brother's killing he leaves
naruto and everyone else alive despite
them posing a direct opposition to his
plans and their consistent insistence on
sticking their noses in when he has
actively stated that he doesn't want
that there's a contradiction at play
here if nothing else matters including
your own well-being then why not get rid
of them here and now well i guess
because while he doesn't want to admit
it there is something else important to
him his friends so while this fight and
mission ends in spectacular failure
naruto and his allies at the very least
left with their lives and a deeper
understanding of the current situation
they need to become stronger i really
enjoyed this arc i felt like it started
strong introduced and established some
really interesting new characters while
reinforcing the themes of responsibility
and highlighted the indoctrination of
young ninja at a new extreme through the
likes of psy who i ended up really
liking in the finish both of the big
fight sequences in this arc centered
around pivotal narrative beats
concerning the likes of naruto sakura
sai yamato and sasuke overall i thought
this arc was efficient focused and
snappy the tenshi bridge sequence had me
at the edge of my seat and it managed to
maintain that tension through the battle
with sasuke and thankfully they not only
managed to continue this goodness into
the next dark but expanded some love to
characters like shikamaru who has since
quickly become one of if not my favorite
character to follow in this story so
let's dive into this arc and see why
it's christmas well okay not quite but
santa's here early to ensure my jingle
balls are all in great shape with the
new performance package from manscaped
the lawnmower 4.0 is the absolute
highlight of this package this cordless
trimmer is not only waterproof and great
for sensitive skin thanks to its skin
save tech but it also features a festive
led light that's perfect for those dark
winter nights but oh what's this is that
the crop preserver and crop reviver in
your stocking or are you just happy to
see me that's right this kit comes with
handy ball deodorant and ball toner
spray to ensure you smell great across
the festive season and hey if you're
feeling the tingle of tinsel up your
nose the weed whacker nose and ear
trimmer has you covered too thanks to
santa 360 degree rotary blades and the
same skin save tech from the trimmer
this thing is wonderful every guy needs
to add manscape to their wishlist this
season and if you've got a special man
in your life that's been extra good this
year then make sure to get him this
awesome performance package it even
comes with a free travel bag and boxers
that's two gifts in one so don't wait go
to manscape.com and use my promo code
not mark 20 to get 20 off plus free
international shipping and 2 free gifts
compete like a ninja
[Music]
sword cannot be beat
my turn
[Music]
naruto sharks and shooters office on
sword and leaf headband accessory seats
sold separate
akatsuki suppression mission right from
the top this arc was phenomenal and
marks the second time the story affected
me emotionally primarily it focuses on
two characters in naruto and shikamaru
with the latter carrying most of the
heavy lifting along with his cell group
after a tragedy befalls them it's rich
with coming-of-age lessons to learn and
through these two characters primarily
we see what that looks like as we
explore their mindsets after each of
their respective setbacks naruto after
coming face to face with sasuke and
failing in the prior arc and shikamaru
who experienced his own unique losses
having completed my notes on this
section i also realized that i didn't
talk or write much about the two main
antagonists of this arc two akatsuki
members called hidan and kakuzu given
the amount of focus the themes
surrounding other characters receive in
this arc i was surprised with just how
much characterization this pair ended up
receiving which only helps i think in
the long run to elevate the struggle to
defeat these two ultimately instead of
appearing stereotypical brandishing all
the personality of a brooding piece of
wood these two genuinely felt like two
individuals distinct from each other
that on a consistent basis break each
other's chops cracking jokes and
insulting each other like two guys in
the office with an established rapport
their powers particularly heat ends
introduce some wonderful opportunities
for shikomaru to play with at various
stages and kakuzu is just straight up a
massive wall the likes of which even
kakashi struggles to overcome priming
him as the perfect target for our hero
of focus in this arc naruto however with
that said i've heard justifiable
complaints aimed at this arc's
conclusion and i'll be exploring them as
well as offering my two cents so let's
start from the start naruto's training
this is what naruto does for effectively
the entire run time of this arc until
the end struggle through training after
failing to help sasuke as it stands i
love training sequences for characters i
find them compelling and often bolster
the trainees characterization and
motivations by showing their tenacity
and determination to achieve their
respective goals through hardship
however something makes this arc stand
out amidst all the other training stints
in the story something that expanded my
understanding of jutsu and placed what i
believe to be a massive near-impossible
task in front of naruto a
near-impossible task with a ridiculously
short time limit through this training
we come to learn from kakashi that the
rosengan a move naruto already struggled
to get this level of competency with is
actually an incomplete jutsu developed
by the fourth hokage himself i thought
that was a really nice touch as it leads
kakashi into a quieter more
inspirational sequence where he
confidently states that he believes in
naruto and that he thinks that someday
he will surpass even the fourth hokage
himself moments like this make me
reflect them when kakashi first met
naruto back in the beginning not knowing
just how far this little kid would go
but through outsole glimpses of his
potential leading to this moment where
he reaffirms naruto's desire and belief
in himself but there's still a lot of
work to do so let's break down exactly
what needs to be done naruto needs to
number one learn to use his change of
nature type jutsu number two then
combine it with the rosengan to complete
a jutsu that even the fourth hokage
couldn't oh and number three to do this
all within a time frame so short that it
would be impossible to complete any of
these steps in isolation this story is
all about surpassing barriers overcoming
the odds and showing the naysayers wrong
but with these exact parameters as a
reader i sincerely felt as though there
was absolutely no way to make this work
other than making some sort of plot
contrivance and that's when kakashi had
one of the most ingenious ideas i've
ever heard in the story
i love when stories can surprise me and
truthfully i never considered this as an
option partially because i wasn't 100 on
the mechanics of the technique but it's
honestly a perfect strategy there isn't
enough time for naruto to practice and
perfect this technique on his own but if
he splits up into hundreds of clones
then he can cram years worth of training
into a comparatively tiny amount of time
and the best part about this strategy is
that this is an approach only naruto
himself can utilize due to the
circumstances of his birth and the
resulting bottomless pit of chakra he
has and what's more is despite the
stress of what has just happened with
sasuke he remains focused willing to
shoulder all of this responsibility time
and time again pushing himself to the
absolute limit his breaking point with
this entire sequence in the story
representing naruto's true strength and
tenacity independent of the fox spirit
and as a result of all of this this
technique when he perfects it it will be
a technique not only uniquely his own
but has been developed with the express
purpose of giving him the strength he
needs to save his friend with the best
part being it will free him from having
to rely on the fox spirit's power
building upon the lessons learned in the
prior arc and so as a continuation of
naruto's story i loved this training
sequence
[Music]
shikamaru's team versus hidan and kakuzu
this is the plotline that gives this arc
its name while out on a suppression
mission to stop the akatsuki personnel
team asuma with shikamaru present runs
into two individuals i touched on
earlier hidan and kakuzu as i think it
should a large portion of this fight
hinges on the readers or our heroes lack
of understanding of the enemy we have no
idea at this point what their powers are
why they're so confident and what on
earth hedan is wearing naturally due to
the mystery surrounding their abilities
the stakes raise themselves considerably
creating an ideal circumstance for
shikamaru to formulate a plan of action
after deciphering what jutsu hedan is
utilizing leading to a brilliant and
absolutely brutal killing strike of
hidden by asuma the squad leader but
wait
sike that's the wrong number
with that and shikamaru zapped of energy
unable to restrain him any longer he's
forced to watch on powerless as asuma
gets stabbed to near death in front of
him in a fashion only hiden could
possibly pull off thanks to his gruesome
and honestly sadistic jutsu moments
before he dies reinforcements arrive
forcing the two akatsuki members to turn
tail and run for it leaving asuma to die
in shikamaru's arms imparting before he
leaves some final words to each of his
students and surprisingly this felt
authentic it felt tragic with an
appropriate level of gravity to it for
sure but what i was surprised by was how
readily i got on board with and
connected to how shikamaru and his cell
group must have been feeling
asuma's death i'm not sure if this will
come as a surprise to anyone but i
didn't expect to care as much as i did
during this sequence it shocked me with
how touching i found this ceremony and
the lengthy amount of time given to this
character's passing and since then i've
wondered why that was assume it wasn't
by any means a character i had an issue
with but i also wouldn't say he was one
i was particularly close to either which
honestly in retrospect made me wish i
had formed more of a bond with this
character across the series instead of
just the last 10 or so chapters but it
did make me wonder why i was feeling as
strongly as i did during this scene and
i think the reason was shikamaru you see
going into a long-running series
completely blind like i am with the
expectation of writing a review each and
every week is kind of like being an
archer without a target being asked to
hit the bullseye i try to make guesses
as to what's important to remark upon
but i'll always miss something when i'm
going in blind it's just the nature of
the beast when i reviewed dragon ball
earlier in the year i found it to be a
very pleasant experience as i knew what
was or was not important and so could
focus on and plan c's for future things
i wanted to talk about like goku's
transformation into the uzaro in the
first arc and how it has a direct
connection in explaining his last
moments with his grandpa who we will
then meet much later in the urinai baba
section i can't do stuff like that with
naruto i can only speak about things
that impacted me on that given week of
reading and hope and pray that i got the
important stuff however shikomaru has
been a character that has time and time
again impressed me to no end initially
he seemed like a disinterested
unmotivated and boring character to make
up numbers for the background cast but
in his tuning exam fight he proved me
wrong after that he seemed like an
interesting character but not one that
would have served a leading role and
that's when the chase for sasuke
happened and i once again was proven
wrong and now i find myself over 300
chapters into this story watching as
this character i never anticipated i
would spend so much time with or connect
to one that has earned his standing
through struggle talent and effort
across the series making myself feel
this loss i think across the entire
story no character has surprised or
impacted me more than shikamaru and what
i really appreciate about this series is
how dedicated and comfortable kishimoto
is in basking in the more quiet moments
whether that be solemn emotional still
or any combination of these i've
recognized him as being an incredible
artist with a particular flair for
action creating some wonderfully kinetic
layouts however his attention to the
quieter moments across this series has
really heightened my experience clearly
on display during asuma's funeral
distant shots of shikamaru informing his
family in a long hallway all the framing
here really helping to sell the
atmosphere kishimoto is going for with
everyone taking the time to commemorate
this noble and much-loved shinobi with
an appropriate amount of focus on the
character of shikamaru and while i
thought all of this was great once i
finished this arc my team suggested i
take a closer look at one specific
episode from the anime one that while
technically filler in many instances
elevated this section of the story to
new heights the manga never reached on
its own
episode 82
episode 82 of shipuden is a beautiful
and i think near perfect addition to the
series filled with stunning
cinematography the series of scenes that
decorate this short but powerful episode
heighten what was in fact the purpose of
shikamaru's portion which is in effect
his coming-of-age story i always find
these types of tales to be profoundly
powerful for a number of reasons
obviously because of their hopeful
relatability but more so because of the
crossroads and lessons that a young
person must learn in order to become an
adult shikamaru doesn't know what to do
with himself and fails to attend the
funeral of his master asuma he wanders
the street sits isolated on his porch
for hours denying his mother's offer for
food until eventually his father asks
him to play him in a game of shogi all
shot from one angle at first to
emphasize the still measured and
reserved nature of the interaction with
shikaku remarking upon his son's
different approach to playing today
citing it as quote forceful the shogi
game itself offers this father and son
the means with which to subtly reach
each other with shikaku using it as a
vehicle to highlight his son's strengths
his gratitude for his son being alive
and teaching him not to shy away from
feeling what he's feeling eventually
reaching a boiling point where the angle
suddenly shifts as shikamaru flips a
table in anger when he's reminded that
asuma is dead shikaku tells him to let
it all out that's sadness fear and anger
the direction is spectacular with
interesting angles close-ups of his
gritted teeth and clenched fists up
until now shikamaru had always been
someone to rely on in a pinch to think
things through with a measured
calculated approach his father saw this
anger remarking on his forceful
uncharacteristic playstyle in the shogi
game and that it's not good to attend a
son's funeral in this scene shikaku
shows shikamaru how to deal with a
tragic reality to allow these natural
feelings to come flooding out allowing
himself to mourn and later that night
armed with a clear head he looks again
at the shogi board recognizing a
particular tile symbolic of his bond
with asuma and just like the shinobi
asuma wanted him to be shikamaru jumps
to action and begins outlining his
counter-attack on those that took his
master and friend from him masterfully
highlighting moments where his plans
fail however this time he centers
himself dispassionately formulating this
plan meticulously there are some
glimpses of moments clearly taken from
the manga in this episode however it's
the pieces of added connective tissue
between these moments that i think
elevated the material far above what it
was in the manga there's nothing
compromised there's no theme devalued
for the sake of extending the run time
of an anime episode everything here
feels well thought out purposeful and
effective in its telling it's exactly
what every anime adaptation of a
long-running show should strive to be
it's a 10 out of 10 brilliant addition
to this tale capping itself off with its
main focus having learned a difficult
but important
[Music]
i'm not sure if this is a controversial
take or not but i'm going to be honest i
like lady tsunade far more than i ever
liked at the third hokage we actually
get to see her work react to drama and
create strategies as the hokage of this
village and its shinobi with this scene
acting as a prime example of that tying
wonderfully together with and
complementing the arc shikomaru
underwent in the anime episode
reflecting on when she lost someone near
and dear to her not wanting that for
anyone else unlike the third hokage
we're able to watch lady tsunade apply a
lesson she learned onto the younger
generation telling and then ordering
shikamaru's cell of three not to go on
some avenging mission in the name of
asuma it's a sound strategic argument
that both speaks to her as a leader and
as a character having learned the exact
same lesson in the arc we were first
introduced to her unlike many characters
which typically act in a binary of
active or reactionary in terms of
engagement with the plot she seems to
tick both boxes when the time calls for
it enacting her will as an active
character onto the story with shikamaru
cell in this instance encouraging
kakashi to lead the cell and as a
reactionary in the scene immediately
following as she formulates a plan of
action and support utilizing the updates
given to her by sakura she's honestly a
fascinating character and one that sits
high in my rankings within this story
[Music]
despite them entering into this scenario
with a newfound vigor and kakashi in tow
i legit felt a greater sense of
forboding entering into this scenario
than i ever thought possible when i
first met these two villains which i
think is a testament to kishimoto's
approach in building them up as a
credible threat complete with emotional
weight enticed shikamaru and his friends
ino and choji and while this action gets
off to a great start with chikamaru's
plan following through as he anticipated
kishimoto ends up utilizing this as an
opportunity to show us how different
types of jutsu react to each other
during this sequence we routinely cut
away to naruto's training and yamato
explaining the dynamics between
different states once we get the basics
of one concept concerning change of
nature kishimoto cuts back to the action
and shows that mechanic in action
through kakashi's lightning slicing up
kakuzu's earth-style jutsu
[Music]
furthermore i love that upon hearing
this from yamato naruto doesn't focus on
what he has that can defeat sasuke but
instead focuses on how he can amplify
and compliment his friend showing us
that saving sasuke is still his one and
only focus there's no resentment no
desire to hurt only concern and love for
his lost companion it's a quick moment
but it once again reinforces the fact
that kishimoto tries to stay true to his
character's motivations at all times
when kakashi's attack reveals kakuzu's
true power separating into four other
opponents the scope of what lies before
shikamaru becomes obvious assuming the
leadership position and formulating a
plan of attack utilizing himself as the
anchoring point of two separate fronts
he's adopted the most work and
responsibility in this group which is a
far cry from the person he once was
someone that hardly ever wanted to exert
effort leading to this awesome sequence
where we as an audience come to fully
understand the scope of shikamaru's plan
that he readied himself for every
contingency and even conceived of a
means with which to dispose of he died
the strategy implemented by shikamaru to
defeat kakuzu was amazing and absolutely
cathartic i mean what a payoff utilizing
the information garnered by asuma to
take down his attackers by pitting their
strengths against each other what an
outstanding effort on behalf of sheikah
[Music]
i think at this point i was thinking in
my head okay so everyone's either
exhausted or not strong enough to take
this dude out the fight itself has been
amazing and a struggle against kakuzu
specifically but at this point i didn't
see a way out of this which i think made
what happens next all the more effective
for me
[Music]
i think what's interesting about this
section or involvement from naruto is
how different people's opinions are on
his appearance here i spoke to one
person about this scene and we
completely disagreed on how naruto's
involvement affected it so in this
section i'm going to explain both and
you can let me know which one you agree
with more let's start with my friends
read on things my friend hated this
decision to include naruto he felt as
though the entire arc had been about ino
shikamaru and choji their relationship
with asuma and that this was their big
battle to avenge their fallen master
going on to say sure shikamaru might get
to have his moment but naruto just
steals everyone's thunder and removes
everyone else's agency he had no
connection to this arc but he just rolls
up because he has to pay off his
training act in short he thought it was
horribly disconnected and as a result
hated it and to be honest depending on
what way you look at this i think that's
a fair way of reading the situation but
it wasn't mine i suppose in the manga
the two stories of this arc are of
shikamaru learning a lesson a naruto
honing a new technique two characters
working through a struggle to overcome a
loss i understood that
were part of that cell and lost their
mentor too however upon reflection their
part in the ark felt very small and not
at all the focus in the end i saw it as
naruto and shikamaru ending an arc that
centered around them specifically the
only one in the cell that i cared about
getting a conclusion to their story with
shikamaru for reasons i already
explained choji and eno did do a bit and
i did enjoy their contribution but they
very much felt to me at least tagged
onto the ark at the very end albeit in a
natural and understandable way keeping
in mind however that i've only read the
manga i have no idea if the anime did
more stuff to help chojianinu feel more
like a bigger part in the end but with
that said i do want to also acknowledge
that while naruto's training was
interesting it didn't necessarily need
to combine with shikomaru storyline
battling the akatsuki though it didn't
bother me as it didn't take away from
shikomaru's moment and from an
in-universe position it makes sense for
naruto to be there as he has plenty to
do with the akatsuki so in the end i
guess the biggest difference between my
opinion and my friends is that i didn't
feel that shojin ino played a big enough
role in the act to secure that big
moment he wanted for them i mean as far
as i'm concerned kakashi contributed
more to that story than they did but in
terms of my reaction to naruto showing
up i don't think i've ever been more
happy to see him as a character
experiencing this honestly felt kind of
fresh too naruto up until now has been
the one that follows the leader and gets
saved or comes in clutch at the end in a
sloppy but effective fashion this on the
other hand feels similar though not
identical to goku showing up to help
fight the ginyu force in the back of my
mind i'm just thinking to myself has he
managed to get strong enough will we see
the perfected jitsu he's been working on
and in addition to that his arrival into
the battlefield comes with it an air of
quiet stoy confidence i could really
feel the progression of his character
emotionally compared to the first arcs
once a character that fought to prove
himself by rushing into dangerous
circumstances without any plan and now
he's fighting specifically for a friend
and implements his shadow clones to gain
precious intel to determine a plan of
attack there's a subtle maturity to
naruto in this fight and it feels
wonderful to see him implement the
lessons he learned in the prior training
section he enjoyed but he falls
short
i think this scene is perfect it's a
gentle but superb reminder that while
naruto has developed and changed over
the course of the story he's still
himself willing to constantly pick
himself up off the ground to try and try
again until he gets the result he's
looking for willing to push himself into
circumstances that are dangerous if they
mean that he can get closer to achieving
his goal of protecting sasuke it's a
wonderful combination of everything i
love about the character and i love the
subtle piece of foreshadowing we get
from the technique through the last
scene we see of naruto training as he's
standing in the middle of a large crater
the attack itself is stunning and one
that eclipses any other effort i've seen
from any other character thus far in the
series capping off with a wonderful but
quiet acknowledgement from kakashi that
naruto has indeed surpassed even him and
i love stuff like that but in all
honesty nothing caps off this fight and
really this arc like shikamaru acting as
he ends god as he is passing judgment
onto him before blowing him up and
burying him underneath meters and meters
of rock and earth couple that with the
beautiful imagery provided and you have
for yourself a cacophony of all the
things i love about kishimoto as a manga
artist i'm not kidding when i say this
that between these two arcs kishimoto i
felt really upped the ante and forced me
to care about things i never thought i
would and of course built upon already
sturdy foundations that brings us to
where i find myself today it's certainly
not the flashiest but i love how this
fight really reflects and plays into the
strategic aspects of the leading
character shikamaru while also feeling
uniquely clever and appropriate for a
ninja styled encounter this fight
shikamaru had with hidden doesn't at all
feel like a fight that could take place
in any other world other than naruto
with the elements it takes advantage of
and as a result it gets extra points
from that for me the character of
shikamaru has come leaps and bounds
farther than i ever thought he could
with his final scene once again
highlighting his fact as the shogi game
between himself and his father conclude
highlighting his acknowledgment of the
responsibility himself and his friends
bear going into the future and his
acceptance to the wife of his former
master to become their guardian and
master in the future i've never seen
shikamaru so motivated and determined to
work hard for a better tomorrow and i
honestly couldn't be happier with the
way this arc ended
[Music]
that's a good cliffhanger next week i'll
be starting spy december by reviewing
toby mcguire's spider-man's one two and
three and in the new year 2022 i will
resume my reviews for naruto and berserk
this really and truly seems to be a
series that keeps on getting bigger and
better and i cannot wait to dive back
into more material with you all then but
for now i'll see you all next week and
thank you all so much for watching
[Music]
dumbo